comme promis nous allons retrouver notre
invité dustin hoffman actuellement à
paris à l'occasion de la sortie de son
dernier film outbreak autrement dit
alerte et hier soir notre invité a été
élevé au rang d'officier des arts des
lettres et des arts et lettres par don
par jacques toubon ici la culture et de
la francophonie
l'égérie d'un très beau glaçon bacall a
élevé elle n'est quant à elle à la
dignité de commandeur des arts et
lettres
dustin hoffman bonsoir très très heureux
de vous recevoir sur ce plateau de
france 2 est ce que ça vous flatte
d'être ainsi et médaillé par le
gouvernement français par les autorités
françaises c'est la première fois j'ai
une médaille de qui que ce soit derrière
et c'est très bien alors tout à l'heure
je vous ai demandé pourquoi elle était
pas à votre refaire de veston vous
m'avez répondu je les vends du jeu les
vendus c'est vrai nom est à la maison
mais les enfants jouent avec
est ce que pour vous c'est une
obligation un peu commercial de venir
faire la promotion de vos films est ce
que vous êtes réellement content d'être
à paris faire du shopping promener vos
enfants si elle pas la sortie de ce film
est ce que vous viendriez une voir aussi
souvent non
la seule fois je suis venu à paris
c'était pour vendre mon âme en fait
c'était pour promouvoir des films est la
seule raison pour laquelle je ne viens
pas c'est que j'ai six enfants et c'est
difficile nous voyons toujours ensemble
et puis quand ils seront grands peut
être que je reviendrai à paris pour mon
plaisir
voilà en tout cas cette fois ils sont
avec vous nous allons parler de votre
film vous partagez avec donald
sutherland la fiche donc de ce film
alerte une sorte de thriller biologique
un film catastrophe sur un virus mortel
qui se propage à une vitesse terrifiante
et qui sème les pouvant dans une petite
ville des etats-unis mais je préfère
laisser au réalisateur de ce film de
wolfgang petersen le soin de vous narrer
cette histoire haletante reportage
pascal deschamps le bon dieu le très
petit copain afrique
c'est l'histoire de l'irruption d'un
virus en afrique
la tâche de dustin hoffman c'est d'aller
là-bas d'identifier ce virus de l'isoler
et d'en empêcher la propagation
si une flag au début tout semble aller
pour le mieux même mais contre toute
attente ce virus apparaît aux états unis
et affectent la population de tout un
village et c'est le drame un drame
terrible auquel dustin hoffman devra
faire face pendant une heure et demie à
illies à 19 morts et des centaines
d'autres contaminés et il se fend pages
qu'on affronte il faut isoler les
malades et je veux dire vraiment les
isoler beliet faut faire rentrer chez
elles toutes les autres personnes une
pour plus quel beau mais c'est ce que
nous faisons ça non ce n'est pas ce que
vous faites pas ce que je viens de
traverser une immense foule
et si une personne a le virus alors dix
d'entre elles l'ont déjà et si l'une
d'entre elles arrivent de cédric binauld
alors nous sommes dans une sacrée merde
et nous sommes déjà dans la merde à
essorer mais bien avant les militaires
avaient déjà isolé ce virus il avait
développé d'antidote
mais garder tout ça secret pour en faire
une arme bactériologique décroche alors
pour eux maintenant la question est de
savoir s'ils vont pas abandonner cette
arme en distribuant l'antidote pour
sauver toutes ces vies et empêcher
l'expansion d'épidémie ou bien s'ils
vont continuer de garder le secret pour
conserver cette arme en chef cuisiner ce
qu'ils vont faire
classé la sphère aux oubliettes y a que
vous qui savez bien que moi qui sait et
personne d'autre retirer ce dossier à
votre amie d'agnès
je ne veux pas que ce sale petits
fouineurs viennent [ __ ] le bordel dans
trente années de travail
alors c'est un film d'une grande grande
efficacité dramatique y'elle suspense
tout à fait voulu des poursuites en
hélicoptère plein de scènes tout à fait
spectaculaire il paraît que vous avez
hésité avant d'accepter ce rôle de
colonel de l'armée américaine oui j'ai
hésité parce que j'ai jamais été jamais
eu ce genre de rôle pour avoir observé
scarpe ederson ford était pas prêt tom
cruise ne l'est pas alors par curiosité
j'ai j'ai essayé de faire quelque chose
avec un homme d'action et bon j'ai suivi
le script et puis je les acceptais le
rôle et j'essaie de donner ma version à
moi de ce tome et parce que cette
interprétation est un peu à l'antithèse
des rôles qu'on vous connais bien de
velléitaire pour ne pas dire da social
gens soient des gens comme ça rit alors
cette histoire de virus mortel qui est
très crédible à cette mini pro tech tout
à fait terrifiante est-ce que vous
personnellement vous êtes vraiment
préoccupés par les problèmes de défense
de l'environnement que j'ai appris de ce
film c'est que ces virus qui le virus
ebola et dans le fion l'entente moto bam
enfin en fait la véritable virus c'est
le virus d'ebola qui a déjà beaucoup
tu es déjà beaucoup de gens
malheureusement en afrique eh bien il ya
des virus comme ça qu'ils vivent depuis
des milliers d'années dans leur propre
environnement qui
ne tue personne mais depuis que nous
sommes entrés dans la forêt la forêt
tropicale et bien voilà c'est c'est
ainsi que nous avons retrouvé ces virus
la théorie avec eux ces virus n'ont pas
de raison de nous ennuyer mais parce que
ils perdent leur habitat naturel
et voilà les gens reviennent ensuite par
avion et puis ça c'est ce qui rend la
catastrophe possible donc ils ne sont
pas venus nous chercher en fait mais
c'est plutôt l'inversé de notre ère la
nature nous montre que le virus peut
être le plus dangereux
et bien c'est l'être humain qui le fait
reculer le plus dangereux pour la nature
vous êtes plongés dans la documentation
médicale pour l'interprétation de ce
rôle c'est vrai vous avez dévoré les les
bouquins de médecine et biologie n'ont
rien mangé
j'avais que deux mois en fait c'est le
nombre de sites décrits dans les
dossiers de presse et vous pouvez avoir
pas mal d'informations par les bandes
vidéo et j'ai vu quelque chose comme 50
heures de vidéo et il n'y a rien dans le
film qu'ils soient de la fiction savez
les laboratoires qui sont quand on a
montré bien quelques-uns qui travaillent
dans le monde c'est d'abord sont très
dangereux et du logement
c'est là que l'on travaille sur ces
russes extrêmement dangereux et certains
de ses techniciens effectivement moeurs
qu en travaillant sur c'est donc ce que
vous voyez sur l'écran est
fondamentalement existe ça existe c'est
vrai dernière question plus personnelle
dustin hoffman vous avez deux oscars à
hollywood pour rain man pour kramer
contre kramer vous avez quatre
nominations pour ces oscars
vous n'avez plus rien à prouver
professionnellement est-ce que vous
travaillez encore pour l'argent pour le
plaisir non dits
elle vient de finir un bon gars il
s'appelle à dd je pense que c'est une
question sur le déficit et je crois que
j'ai eu un déficit intellectuel et c'est
bien pour ça pour le réparer céline gold
et c'est pour ça les gens qui ont ce
genre de déficit doivent passer leur vie
à prouver ce qu'ils sont ce que je fais
peut-être enfin peut-être qu'un jour
j'arrêterai de prouver à d que je fais
j'essaie de le faire chaque matin je
vous demande pardon je demande pardon au
monde excusez moi faut que je profite je
suis le sien finement dustin hoffman
d'être venu nous voir ce soir je
rappelle la sortie donc de ce film
passionnant vraiment un vrai thriller
alerte qui sort la semaine prochaine
notre semaine sur tous les écrans de
france maintenant nous allons parler de
choses
infiniment plus grave